yeah thank you very much
Grisha I am from zalando I am NOT Chan
so because Shen was the original
colleague of mine who submitted this
talk okay so before I begin thank you
very much for having me here
good afternoon everyone I'm quite
excited to be here because of it's not a
courtesy I really have two good reasons
one reason is that I'm by accident here
I didn't mean to be at this conference
the story was that sharing a colleague
of mine someone on my team he submitted
a proposal to this conference about our
team and a B testing at Zalando the day
the proposal was accepted to this
conference he figured out that he is
going he was good he would be in Russia
watching football on this day right and
that's the photo of Chen is a picture of
him in Kazan Russia hours before the
game between Germany and South Korea
maybe some people understand the the
importance of this game right so the
second reason I am excited to be here is
that yeah okay just a second the second
reason I'm glad to be here is that as a
matter of fact I used to work here at at
the Sheraton in research for six years I
was located on a different campus it may
be like a couple of miles from here
but the next building here is the HR
headquarters of charity and each tab
each time I got my contract prolonged or
signed contract I had to come here and
to send the documents it was like very
nice emotions coming to this place okay
I'm going to talk I'm going to talk
about a/b testing at Zalando this talk
is quite it's quite basic so I'm just
I'm only touching some more advanced
topics before we go on I would like to
ask you how many of you have never heard
anything
about a/b testing before please raise
your hands no one okay good think so
please raise your hands if you feel
comfortable explaining p-values to
anyone else
Oh quite some quite some so what I'm
going to promise you for those who don't
understand p-values you are not going to
understand them after this talk right so
I'm not going to trying I'm going I'm
not going to try to explain people's
p-values to you but rather to to get
their idea what is behind the p-values
right if if there is one thing you could
learn this talk is that when looking at
noisy things every possible outcome is
really possible right and sometimes you
see things that are not there and
sometimes you don't see things that are
there right and the main difficulty of a
B testing or like any comparative
studies is to be able to tell apart is
to be able to tell how often you do
those two mistakes about seeing things
that are not there and about not be able
to see things that are there there so I
would like to give you this first slide
about spurious correlation there is a
whole webpage with graphs like this in
this particular example what we've got
here is the cheese consumption
correlated with number of people that
died in a particular way right and you
see that the coefficient of correlation
is is close to 95% right when you see
data like this okay there is a whole
whole webpage full of these graphs
it's called televisin comps I can go
there and double-check them the graphs
right so if you see data like this the
first question is are those things
connected to each other right is it by
chance or is it not by chance okay one
more one more example from from this
from this side is another like people
died in some other way
a number of movies Nicolas Cage start in
right with a slight limb with a slightly
less correlation of 67% okay so and the
last one is the divorce divorce rating
in one state in the United States of
America and consumption of margarine
right if you look at the data so you see
that those correlations right but you
the first reaction would be what the
heck is going on here right it doesn't
apply anything maybe there is a good
reason why the consumption of margin is
correlated to the number of divorces
maybe not how would they go about
deciding whether it's the case or not so
going back to the case with oh no sorry
so if you if you go like into the world
of e-commerce so Atlanta we we sell like
fashion items shoe shoes I don't know
clothes clothing beauty items we've got
like also very similar effects in the
sense that we see two things correlated
with each other and the question is can
we conclude that one thing is is driving
the other one for example he introduced
like a new new voucher campaign for new
subscriptions and you see like increase
and increasing in in daily subscriptions
can you can you claim that this this
effect was forced or promoted by this ad
campaign so you introduced like a new
button a new color of the buy button and
you see that the that you see that your
daily revenues go our little go up a
little bit does it automatically mean
that you the choice of the color of the
button has any influence on that right
so basically the idea of a be testing is
about uncovering such relationships okay
so how would you go about how would you
go about the thing with Nicolas Cage so
you would probably if you if you had the
budget I don't think that it's feasible
to try to spend that much money on that
you can ask Nick
second year or two off and measure the
number of death death by drowning in
impulse right and if you do this kind of
experiment and if you see that after
after Nicolas Cage has stopped to act in
movies so if you see that this causes
some changes in the in the other
variable only after that you can at
least have some chances that you can say
okay maybe one thing is maybe the one
thing is related to the to the other
right and when you talk about a/b tests
like probably most of you know that they
should be controlled so it means that it
means that you need like a control group
that you've got like no treatment in
this case that would be like the years
without Nicolas Cage starring any film
and in any films so they should be
randomized in the sense that you perform
your abhi tests on on subjects that are
representative I mean if you yeah
you think about the sample size because
I mean if you're looking like for very
small effects you need a lot of samples
now in order to be in order to be able
to resolve this effect and of course
you've got to think about yeah you've
got the probably the first question or
the most important question that you're
going to ask yourself is the data that I
am looking at the differences between
control and treatment can it be
explained just by random noise so in
this audience for example I could split
I could split the whole the whole
audience into halves like to the left to
the left and to the right of me and I
could for example I could calculate the
the average shoe size right and of
course that that of course the numbers
that would come out of it for the left
side of the audience here and for the
right side of the audience here that
wouldn't be the same number right there
would be slightly different or maybe not
deaths life
then the question is is this difference
really doesn't represent anything or is
it just by by chance due to the fact
that it's just a finite number of people
in the audience right so that's that's
the question that trying to answer here
okay so that's the thing so I skip next
slide and show you this one of my
favorite xkcd comics is about this
correlation causation maybe many people
know it so the last point I think is
which is important here is that yeah
this last may be right that's the point
here right so maybe there was like a
connection between taking the class
understanding statistics better maybe
there was not right so now back to the
land oh so it's the land oh you've got a
separate team which is responsible for
building and supporting and internal a
bit testing - there are about 15 people
including some back-end engineers some
front-end engineers and for research
engineers the research engineers myself
included are responsible like for this
statistical interpretation of results
right and this tool has been around for
maybe the last year or two currently as
of this week we've got more than 50
tests life tests that are running and
collecting the data right and our aim is
to is to grow scalable to hundreds and
maybe thousands of tests right if there
are many things that you have to think
about if you do a/b testing on such a
scale please do ask me afterwards about
this I don't have that much time going
into the details here one reason why for
example one one reason why for example
the Wando decided to go like forum for
an own a be testing tool is the is the
conflicts between potential conflicts
between tests so suppose that in one
test you you
you make a change very introduced like a
blue font on the default background and
the in the other test you test the
different color of background and people
that are in the treatment groups of both
tests they would see like blue text on
blue background and they wouldn't be
able to organize anything right so we
were not that far
currently but this automatic conflict
recognition is part or is part of our
goals right but trying in order to be
able to run a be testing on scale we
have to be able to recognize this
potential conflicts automatically we
still don't know how to do this in
general but we are going there okay a
little bit of the software engineering
perspective so our tool is is a set of
services and more or less it's three
three main pillars we've got some
bookkeeping for the tests so basically
that's a bunch of skaila of services
implemented in Scala and it's basically
as I said for for bookkeeping so who is
the owner of the testament the test
should be started what's the end date of
the test
what is the goals of the tests the
choice of the kiparis and so on so
that's quite a low load service so there
are not many not much automatic
interaction with that right the second
service is the assignment service
basically what we are offering to our
stakeholders within company each term is
that each time then they have to make a
decision between two variants between
the control and the treatment variant so
they perform a request to this
assignment service and we do the
randomization for them right and its
service this randomization our site
serves two purposes first we can ensure
that randomization is done properly
right so you choose the weights of the
variants in the tests in
at the beginning of the test for example
you're giving 70% to the treatment group
and for the 30% to the control group and
we kind of got like we can ensure that
the variance splitting will be as close
as possible to this 70 to 30 percent
right and probably the most interesting
set of services for this conference is
analysis services so the closer we get
to the data actually to the actual data
the more like Python code we've got and
this analysis services and they kick in
once all the data has been collected so
far yeah yeah
so we don't split in advance and the
stakeholders can pick the duration
advance bid 50% to 50% or maybe 70% at
30%
so how we do splitting at it's basically
hashing the user ID and whatsoever and
putting it into like some deterministic
function right so it's not I mean it's
it's you the randomized split right so
we can recover each time based on the
user ID we can recover the variant in a
deterministic manner each time yeah yeah
because you cannot do this very easily
after the test has started because some
users might happen have seen the the one
variant and then end up being at the
other one right and that could introduce
problems that one of the reasons right
we want to keep this assignments this
split splits like in a coherent way
across the test right yeah all right and
about the right I was talking about
analysis pipeline so basically most of
our data comes at the mom
from google analytics tables and
bigquery and there is like several steps
like building the the the source code of
the SQL query to fetch the data then
doing some data pre-processing then
executed executing query then do some
data pre-processing and finally data
ends up being analyzed by expand that's
our open source Python library for
analyzing results of a be tests I'm
going to talk about this a little bit
later just saw a slide and this expand
services a certain open open source
library it produces the p-values right
whatever they they might be okay and I'm
trying to get a little bit of your
attention to this expand project it's on
open source github please look into that
if you feel interested in it please
think about it may be committing
submitting pull requests we would be
glad to to see them and it can can do a
couple of things that can do like very
basic t-test it can do comparison by
bootstrapping and it has some code for
Bayesian analysis of the test results
and it's nice thing please do check the
library out and okay so what I'm going
to do next is just we're going to yeah
why all this why all this fuss about
different like testing approaches and so
on so the thing is that in statistics
like the set or maybe the good news is
that you don't prove anything right in
statistics you cannot prove that one
okay maybe you can but it's not the
usual way of thinking about things you
usually you don't prove that I don't
know you've got better sales on weekends
then then during the week right so the
usual tool of analysis and statistics is
like rejection hypothesis
so you're not trying to prove that the
earth that the earth is round but you're
rather trying to disprove like boring
hypothesis right they're going to
they're trying to disprove the things
that there is no no no difference
between like treatment and the control
variant right and that's the more or
less the the the core of the of the
approach right to give you a better
feeling maybe like a very very simple
thing that we could think about
altogether I'm giving you a coin right
you can flip this coin and observe the
not the the heads or tails right and now
now I'm asking you could you make a
decision as to whether this coin is fair
as to the probabilities of heads and
tails are the same right and if you if
you start thinking about this very
simple example you start I mean you've
got most of the questions that appear
during like an a/b test right you have
to choose your null hypothesis which
could be that your affair is that your
coin is is fair so the probabilities of
tails and heads I equal and our 50% you
have to think about you have to you've
got to think about your budget in the
sense how often you're going to flip the
coin right because flipping coin may be
not a big business but doing like a B
test cost some money right and depending
on on the particular a bit as if you
offering vouchers for example some
discount vouchers it could it could cost
some money to come from here right once
you've got the data you've got to you've
got you've got to have like protocol or
maybe an algorithm how to decide whether
this data this particular set of this
particular set of heads and tails
whether it's compatible with your null
hypothesis right and only if if you
think that the data is highly improbable
under the assumption of the null
hypothesis your
rejecting it and you're saying okay the
coin is not fair and what happens is
that basically what we are looking here
is a binary classifier right because we
know that coin has a certain state
either fair or not fair and from data
generated by this coin we are trying to
make a decision about the yeah we trying
to recognize the state right and since
flips are random and we've got a finite
number of coin flips our decision is not
perfect it's it's noisy right and so
this confusion matter I didn't know I
didn't know it was called confusion
matrix before yesterday right okay so on
the one dimension you've got the actual
state of the coin but it's fair or not
fair and on the y-axis we got our
conclusion right that we draw from the
data and well for outcomes possible two
of them are kind of the right one so if
the coin is fair and we think that the
coin is fair it's like a false positive
true positive if the coin is not fair
and we also believe that the coin is not
fair like it is true negative but those
red those those red non diagonal ones
that's that's the the errors that we're
going to make right and the whole idea
about those all those people is
confidence and power of thing off of
your statistical test is is to be able
to control those those red guys here
right maybe one more example here at the
airport when you go through this metal
detector thing right if you don't have
any metal things on you it it it should
not go off but it can sometimes go off
that would be your false positive events
if you've got some if you've got for
example I don't know like something like
very heavy made of metal on you you go
through the detector and doesn't off
that would be like a false negative
right so the thing is that you're trying
to make those
read events as few as possible and the
difficulty here is that if you're trying
to optimize for say for false positives
to make as to like to be having like as
few false positives as possible like
basically believing to see an effect
there is the there is no effect you are
you are going to sacrifice the defaults
negatives for example for every person
this this metal detector could be set up
in a such way that it goes off for like
for any person so it would have like
extremely high sensitive like in like an
extremely high sensitive but sensitivity
but the number of false positives would
be like very very large right if you are
trying to optimize for false negatives
you can decrease the sensitivity of the
like the physical sensitivity of the
device so it would not go off very often
so probably you will not have like any
false positives but you will end up
having like false negatives a lot of
false negatives right that's that's just
one coin or that's just one metal
detector trust complication that comes
into play here is that when you do an
a/b test you are not looking at just one
KPI you are not looking for example at
the weekly revenue or maybe some
click-through rates or whatever like
subscription rate what you are looking
very often ad is set of KPIs so it means
that you've got you're testing several
hypotheses at the same time and since
you've got like nonzero false positive
rates for your single test the the false
positive rate for the for all of them
seen as just one test will be
significantly higher right suppose that
so I'm giving here an example suppose
that you have a protocol you have a
device or whatever method to to classify
between fair
and unfair coin with 5% false positive
rates so it means that so it means that
if a coin is fair in 5% of such coins
you will you would say that okay coin is
unfair so if you're trying to if you're
trying to apply this method to
classifying like two coins at the same
time in nearly 10% of the cases you will
be producing like a false positive right
because the probability that two coins
are two fair coins recognized as fair at
the same time is larger than then
recognizing just one coin as unfair
right and if you increase this number of
coins or if if you increase the number
of your KPIs you see that basically at
like somewhere between 10 and 20 things
if you're testing like around like 15
things at the same time with this
predefined quite low significance of 5%
you will have like 50 percent of false
positives right so remember the first
three graphs I was showing to you so it
was like some correlations between
between things that seemed absolutely
unrelated to each other right
that's exactly there is also false
positive correlations of spurious
correlations so if you if you go you if
you go through the data sufficiently
long if you're trying to look for things
like
form one more things you will have some
positive correlations like spurious
correlations by just by the nature of of
yeah just because things are random okay
so another example to that if you go to
being being completely healthy person
going to a doctor and being subjected to
a number of tests the more tests are
performed on you the most the
probability of finding something that we
don't have right okay
many doctors don't know about that right
so talk to your doctor before you do
like lots of tests next time
okay there is a remedy against this is
to set up your threshold thresholds in
them like two two smaller values if
you've got questions to this please ask
me afterwards and also one more thing
which seems to be extremely important
for our stakeholders you set up a test
which we think we will take maybe the
next month or maybe two what the first
thing that would they that the
stakeholders the owners of the test
would tell you is it possible to get
results faster than four weeks or eight
or eight weeks right they would say
maybe we could look at the intermediate
test results every day and as soon as
it's significant as soon as we see any
effect we would stop the test and we say
okay we've got the effect of this test
it's not the way it's working
right so you have to keep in mind that
each time you ask the question is there
an effect or is there no effect is LA
it's like asking Homer here as are we
there yet and the answer that Homer
gives you back is a random one okay it
has like quite a high probability of
being in the correct
it has quite high probability of being a
correct answer but sometimes the answer
is not correct and more often you know
you ask them more is the probability
higher the probability that you will
have like some spears spurious
significance okay and the last very very
last thing for the last two minutes in
this conference BM talking so I mean
it's like all around the data science
like probabilities probabilistic methods
my impression is that it's like
statistics and probabilities is not the
ultimate answer so if any of you have
background in finance and economics so
it's they know mum I think people from
from that feel they know much better
about this then
then maybe many of the data scientists
including myself so statistics is just
the is about counting things how often
your your prediction is correct or not
correct what you are interested in on
the other side is like as decision
should I go for the change as suggested
by this ib test or should I keep the old
version right and decision is is the
third pillar here so here we got our
data here we got the statistics and the
last thing is the decision how to go
from the data to statistics is more or
less straightforward
it might be quite involved and difficult
but conceptually counting things is kind
of its feasible but to go from
statistics to decisions is nothing is a
business because you need more
information so here's an example of the
game I could play against you you would
have a higher chance of winning you will
be winning five times as often as I will
do but I will end up having more money
right and my decision to enter this game
or not to enter this game will not be
based about the statistics of the chance
of the chances of of to win in this game
but rather they would depend on the
expected expected utility or the
expected outcome so going back to a B
test in the diagonal cases you should be
able to recognize the profit right if
you see a positive effect in your test
you're allowed a new feature a new
version you should be able to quantify
it I will make X more money with it if I
don't see effect I will save my costs by
not rolling this out but here in those
two guys you are going probably to lose
some money that would be that is your
downside and it's not about how often
you're going to lose your money but
rather how often you're going to lose
your money times the amount you are
going to lose right
so if you're trying to make a decision
based on the result of a B test or like
any other statistical approach please
don't go don't decide based on the
statistics only please ask your finance
guys what is what are the financial
upsides and downsides of the
decision and only that together with the
statistics together with the
probabilities you can estimate the you
can estimate the the most sensitive
decision right so be at the londo so in
my team we are still in the very in the
beginning of this journey we know how to
produce statistics we know how to
produce probabilities we know how to
answer our customers questions about how
probable is that that's whatever the new
variant is better than they are old one
but we still we don't have just we don't
have the data right that very often it's
complicated because if you're I don't
know it really depends on your business
logic and how money you are spending on
that how much money you how much money
money are going to make make a dent if
if it's really better than the old thing
you're doing so please give it a thought
it's I don't think it's it's quite
straightforward as the rest yeah and
that's all that's my last
that's my last message thank you very
much
[Applause]
hey thank you very very much I have
infinite questions but I will not ask
them because I will give the audience a
chance to ask questions any questions
okay hi I have a simple question because
you said that your package implements
classical tests like bootstrap bayesian
tests but in the end in your work what
do you use classical hypothesis testing
bayesian staff permutation test so we've
got some code for Bayesian analysis we
don't use it in the production because
it's it's orders of magnitude slower so
we on our life tests we run an analysis
like every six hours more or less like
four times a day maybe five times a day
and on the amount of data we've got to
sample from the posterior distribution
in a Bayesian approach takes hours or
sometimes days we cannot afford that we
don't know how to do it any faster so
most of the times we do like very
straightforward t-test whatever
sometimes we do bootstrapping in a
manual mode it's not automated yet we've
got the code for the Bayesian stuff
maybe for some explorative data for data
analysis but it's not part of our daily
automatic pipeline maybe if you know
solution to that how to do Bayesian
things faster yeah I would like I would
like to know about it is this okay
Thanks thanks for your talk I was
curious if we could I'm here yeah I was
curious we could talk a bit about what
kinds of experiments you run like is it
new products that you're putting on the
site new features new redesigns or is it
a mix of everything okay one test that
okay so a good friend of mine a
colleague of mine and the Londo works as
a product specialist for the team that
the final step of the sorting so if
you're looking for black jeans at
solando you will see like a number of
results and the team is responsible for
the sorting of the top whatever hundreds
relevant results to you to your to your
request and what they test they test
different machine machine learning based
approaches to the Search Search that
would be one of the tests so it's kind
of meta meta a bit as testing like one
machine learning algorithm against the
other one just an example but there are
also boring ones there are boring ones
that they do they shift some input field
in the front end from one corner to the
other corner of course we've got a lot
of tests like this - I have one question
what's the most egregious
like terrible mistakes you've seen I
just you know I'm sure you've seen a ton
what's the most egregious mistakes
you've seen that al kind of dangerous
and should be avoided in this kind of
analysis that is statistical connected
to a lot of noise exposed to a lot of
noise in that kind of stuff so number
one would be like overzealous data
mining so in our system the user before
they set up before they run a test they
have to pick up a set of KPIs so
basically what their what numbers they
are going to compare to each other
between different variants that could be
either now some revenues some
click-through rates and we tell them
with all stakeholders the fewer KPIs the
better and they would for example go
with three three key pairs in the
beginning they wouldn't see any
significance in those three key pairs
but they would say maybe we could run a
more like manual analysis for four new
KPIs that were not part of the initial
test plan and see some significance in
there and of course if you've got 5%
significance and you choose 20 kpi's
we'll have like at least one of them on
average as significant false positive
that one thing and early stopping of
course right because it's quite
different to explain people like the
more you look the more conservative ever
you have to be with your threshold
because you're spending have to spend
your false positive budget over the
whole number of times you are looking
into their intermediate results yeah
it's related so summarizing that would
be something related to multiple
hypothesis testing problem yeah we have
time for and one more short question if
there is okay so thank you very much
narrowly for a really fascinating talk
and
[Applause]